Finally, we wanted to present our effect size measures. And again, this could
be Cohen's d, r squared or others or both. In terms of APA style, simply write
d equals values rounded to 2 decimals or r squared equals, decimal place, and
the values rounded to two decimals. One thing to notice, is in APA style, we
don't use a leading zero for situations in which we have proportions. If the
value cannot be greater than 1, we don't need a zero in this spot right here.
So for r squared, because it's a proportion, we cannot have a value greater
than one. So we'd write it just like this. So for example if r squared were
0.17, you would just write it 0.17 with no zero here. Cohen's d can be greater
than one. So if we had a Cohen's d of let's say, 0.25, we would write d equals
0.25.